هذه الصور التي وصلت قناه العربيه الان
وهي صور خاصه بقناه العربيه
اصابات بين المدنيين في داخل المستشفى
الدولي في منطقه الخرطوم بحري اذا هذه
الصور من داخل المستشفى الدولي حيث تتوافد
الاصابات بين المدنيين الى هذا المستشفى
على في سياق المعارك الدائره الحاليه في
الخرطوم والتي لم تسلم منها مناطق الخرطوم
الثلاث نتحدث عن ام درمان او ان كانت اقل
نسبيه من بقيه المناطق نتحدث عن منطقه
الخرطوم بحري والخرطوم العاصمه ايضا اذا
هذه الصور
للمصابين من المدنيين في احدى في احد
المستشفيات العاصمه الخرطوم جراء هذه
المعارك الدائره هناك ايضا اشتباكات
مشاهدينا في منطقه الاوبيض في منطقه
الفاشر ايضا غرب السودان هناك في مروي في
مناطق مختلفه من السودان ونتابع معكم هذه
الصور
للاصابات في مستشفى الخرطوم جراء المعارك
لمتابعه المزيد
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات